China, china, china
Donald Trump centró buena parte de su campaña
en atacar el libre comercio y denunciar la
supuesta competencia desleal de países como
México y sobre todo China.
Sí, amigos, en otros vídeos anteriores ya
contamos que China fue tan importante en su
discurso electoral, que prácticamente podemos
referirnos a Trump como el candidato anti-China.
Trump se comprometió a poner fin al papel
del gigante asiático como la fábrica del
mundo y traer de vuelta a los Estados Unidos,
fábricas y empleos
fijando aranceles altísimos a los productos
chinos.
Ahora bien, muchas de sus tesis se basan en
planteamientos erróneos y desatar
una guerra comercial con China tendría para
los Estados Unidos consecuencias muy graves.
“Nos quitan nuestros trabajos”, “destruyen
nuestras fábricas”, “manipulan su moneda”,
“ejercen la competencia desleal”,
son solo algunos de los mensajes que Donald
Trump utilizó sistemáticamente para denunciar
el modelo de crecimiento chino durante una
campaña en la que se llegó a referir a este
país como “el ladrón más grande de todos
los tiempos”.
Hoy sabemos que esta estrategia funcionó.
Según las llamadas exit polls y diversos
estudios llevados a cabo tras la campaña,
muchos electores apostaron por Donald Trump
porque este les ofrecía una solución clara
a un problema que muchos estadounidenses padecen:
la pérdida de empleo en la industria manufacturera.
Y es que, en las tres últimas décadas, EEUU
ha perdido más de un tercio de todos los
empleos industriales.
Sólo desde el año 2000, varios millones
de trabajadores han perdido su puesto de trabajo
en fábricas que pagaban 25 dólares la hora
y que,
en la mayoría de los casos, solo han podido
encontrar salida en empleos del sector servicios
donde los salarios no alcanzan ni la mitad.
- "Heinz, el mayor productor mundial de Kétchup despedirá a 1.350 trabajadores en Estados Unidos y Canada".
El mensaje es el siguiente: si restringimos
el acceso de productos chinos, si terminamos
con su competencia desleal, nuestras fabrican
volverán a florecer y, con ellas, los puestos
de trabajo se multiplicarán.
Una idea que también ha utilizado, como sabéis
con México.
Ahora bien, ¿qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
Si echamos un vistazo rápido a las estadísticas
comerciales podríamos llegar a pensar que
Donald Trump está en lo cierto:
al año las compras de EEUU a China superan
en más de 350.000 millones de dólares a
las ventas
, de tal forma que, atentos, este déficit
comercial supone casi tanto como la mitad
de todas las exportaciones de Latinoamérica
al resto del mundo.
-"Trump culpó a China de ser el causante de la mitad del déficit comercial de EEUU
y afirmó que el país asiático  no es una economía de mercado".
Bueno, este dato parece dar la razón
a la tesis de que China está secando a los
Estados Unidos ¿verdad?
Pues, esperad un momento, porque esto no es
así del todo.
Las exportaciones chinas hacia América no
son exclusivamente de productos de empresas
chinas.
De hecho, más de la mitad de todas las exportaciones
chinas a EEUU corresponden bien a productos
de empresas estadounidenses bien a productos
que estas necesitan para completar su producción
en los Estados Unidos.
Me explico, pongamos como ejemplo el caso
de Apple.
Cada IPhone que se produce en China es exportado
a los EEUU, aproximadamente por 180$.
Ahora bien, previamente China tuvo que importar
172$ en componentes de otros países como,
por ejemplo, Corea del Sur, Japón, Alemania
o los propios EEUU.
El resultado es que el ensamblaje en China
solo aportó 8$ al valor del producto, pero
las estadísticas de EEUU lo recogen por 180$,
distorsionando así la realidad de las relaciones
comerciales.
Y por supuesto, tanto los beneficios como
los mejores puestos de trabajo, como los de
diseño e investigación, se quedan en los
Estados Unidos.
Por otra parte, la tendencia está cambiando,
y desde 2005 las exportaciones de EEUU a China
se han triplicado.
El gigante asiático compra como loco aviones
de Boeing, coches de General Motors, ropa
de Nike, o miles de toneladas de café de
Starbucks.
Tan solo en el caso de Apple China genera
el 20% del negocio mundial, 53.000 millones
cada año ¡Qué se dice pronto!
La guerra comercial prometida por Trump podría
tener un efecto devastador sobre las compañías
estadounidenses y por extensión sobre economía.
Porque a nadie le quepa la menor duda de que
China respondería inmediata y las empresas
de EEUU perderían el acceso a un mercado
de más de 1.300 millones de personas ¡menudo
negocio!
Y es que, amigos, el proteccionismo nunca
ha funcionado, y la verdad, difícilmente
esta vez será diferente.
Pero los efectos no terminan aquí.
De cumplirse las amenazas de Trump hacia China
los primeros damnificados serían los propios
ciudadanos estadounidenses, especialmente
la clase media y las personas con menos recursos.
Los aranceles y la sustitución de productos
y componentes fabricados en China elevarían
los costes de las empresas y con ellos los
precios de venta de una infinidad de productos.
¿El resultado?
El desplome en la capacidad de consumo de
la mayoría de los estadounidenses, entre
ellos por supuesto de los propios votantes
de Trump.
Y encima las grandes marcas del país perderían
capacidad competitiva respecto a las de otros
países
¡Menudo negocio!
Así, no resulta extraño que el Wall Street
Journal alerte de una posible recesión si
los planes de Trump cumpliese su palabra.
Pero es que, además, Donald Trump basa sus
planteamientos en una gran mentira: la pérdida
de poder industrial de los Estados Unidos,
lo que ¡es absolutamente falso!
Es verdad, desde 1979, año de empleo record
en el sector, en EEUU han desaparecido más
de 7 millones de empleos industriales, pero,
eso no quiere decir que haya ocurrido lo mismo
con la producción.
De hecho, desde ese año la producción industrial
real se ha más que duplicado y hoy en día
se encuentra solo ligeramente por debajo del
pico máximo que se alcanzó en 2007.
- "Con sus aviones made in USA, Airbus espera ser reducir costos y hacer más competitivos sus precios".
Es decir, no es que EEUU haya perdido capacidad
industrial, es que hoy es mucho más fuerte
en este ámbito.
El problema, no es China, sino que las fábricas
ya no necesitan emplear a tanta gente como
antes porque buena parte del trabajo está
automatizado.
General Motors, sin duda una de las corporaciones
más emblemáticas del país, funciona hoy
con aproximadamente una tercera parte de los
más de 600.000 trabajadores que tuvo en los
70, y aun así produce más automóviles y
camiones que nunca.
Ojo, esto no quiere decir que hoy no haya
trabajo en EEUU, todo lo contrario: hoy trabaja
en este país más gente que en cualquier
otro momento de la historia.
Lo que ocurre es que estamos viviendo un cambio
de paradigma que nos obliga a adaptarnos,
pero que nadie se confunda: el pasado no va
a regresar.
En resumen, podemos enviar directamente a
la papelera el discurso de Trump.
Dificultar el comercio con China, México,
y supongo que también con otras potencias
industriales emergentes, como Vietnam,
no solo no serviría para nada sino que además
podría destruir millones de puestos de trabajo
adicionales y dificultar la adaptación necesaria
al nuevo paradigma económico hacia el que
nos caminamos.
En la misma línea, también podemos determinar
que no pare una estrategia acertada demoler
el buen trabajo que Obama había llevado a
cabo en el Pacífico.
Donald Trump ha decidido, de forma coherente
con sus tesis proteccionistas, tumbar el TPP,
el acuerdo de libre comercio más grande de
todos los tiempos,
que afectaba a más del 40% del PIB global
y que suponía una oportunidad extraordinaria
para que las empresas estadounidenses hubiesen
generado millones de nuevos puestos de trabajo.
- "El presidente electo anunció que en su primer día de gobierno va a iniciar el proceso para que su país se salga del TPP".
Algunos estudios hablan de que las exportaciones
de EEUU hubiesen crecido, gracias al TPP,
en más de 350.000 millones de dólares, al
tiempo que los consumidores hubiesen incrementado
su capacidad de compra y las empresas sus
beneficios.
De momento, mientras EEUU decide tumbar muchas
de las políticas que lo convirtieron en el
país más rico de la tierra, China, el gran
enemigo de Trump mueve ficha y se predispone
a liderar su propio, TPP.
De forma contraria a sus promesas, el legado
de Trump puede ser el de un EEUU mucho más
decadente y menos competitivo, es decir, el
resultado opuesto a las esperanzas de una
gran parte de sus votantes.
Bien, espero que te haya gustado el vídeo,
si ha sido así no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik,
dando clic aquí si aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.